hi there steve kaufman here this is the
third
of these 12 videos
that will accompany you through these
three months where you are working to
make a breakthrough in your language
learning
i want to focus on different sort of
activities different aspects of
the things that you can do to improve
during these three months these 90 days
and today i want to talk about listening
the importance of listening how to make
listening more
effective and
why it's so important
so
as you know
modern language acquisition
research indicates that input input of
comprehensible and compelling material
is
vital to our
acquisition of the language it's not a
matter of explaining the language or
drilling you in the language it's a
matter of you exposing yourself to a lot
of compelling content obviously this can
be done by reading but
listening has a lot of advantages
listening is easy to arrange you can do
it anywhere you can do it five minutes
at a time 10 minutes at a time
we have this lovely uh print behind me
one of my favorite prints of southern
france done by van gogh but this also
happens to be our kitchen here in palm
springs and it's a major listening area
for me because i'm usually the one who
cleans up
i also use the swifter to clean the
floor
any activity that i do around the house
i can do while listening
so listening is very convenient in that
regard
it's easy too it's sometimes you fade
out sometimes you focus better
um
it's easy to do it can be a little more
challenging to read and of course it
takes a lot more work to arrange to find
someone who can speak to you in the
language that you're learning so
listening is the easiest thing to
arrange
and it's very effective i find that that
reading helps with vocabulary
acquisition but listening prepares you
for speaking especially if you listen
more than once to the same content at
least at the beginning of your journey
in a new language later on as you
progress you don't need to listen more
than once when you're at a sort of a
high intermediate level but when you're
at the beginner level i find very it
very useful to listen more than once to
the same content and when i say more
than once i'm talking 30 40 50 times
uh in my recent efforts at learning
arabic and farsi and even greek before
then where we have these mini stories
which use the most frequently used verbs
in the language and they repeat within
the same story three four five times the
same structures the same verbs maybe
slightly different forms of the verb or
different tenses
and so this exposure repetitive exposure
and then listening to it over and over
and over again noticing different things
each time prepares your brain makes the
brain more familiar with the language
and so then when you go to speak you
find that you're able to speak much
earlier at least in my own case much
earlier than was the case before so
reading excuse me listening is easy to
arrange you can do it whenever you want
and it's tremendously powerful for
improving your speaking and also your
pronunciation now
one should
equip oneself for effective listening so
first of all if you are listening at
link if you're listening to a lesson
make sure that you download that to your
playlist because then you'll always have
it with you and it goes across different
devices so if i save
a lesson the audio to a playlist on my
computer it is automatically available
for me on my ipod nano
it's available for me on my
ipad the larger ipad which i use mostly
for reading this i use if i go to the
gym
it's available for me on my iphone which
is filming this video
and so not only is it readily available
but
it tracks how much listening you do so
you develop meaningful statistics on how
much you've been listening across the
various months that you've been studying
the language and you can look at these
in your profile at link per language or
if it's one language when did you start
when are you doing more listening less
listening and all of that is very
helpful uh so make sure you use the
playlist one other thing about
listening
personally i'm a great fan of these
little guys the
uh airpods now you might think i'm a
walking promotion for apple but it is
these are tremendously convenient but
you can also use these conventional
um
earpods but the thing is get something
that is is functional that you like that
suits your budget so that you can be
equipped to listen
and to track your listening
on
online
so
that's what i wanted to emphasize that
that language learning is not
uh
a matter of of getting a grammar book
and devouring this grammar book in fact
if anything i find after a while after
you've heard certain structures in the
language you become curious and you may
look up a grammar point but the main
thing is to do a lot of listening and
reading
and the listening and maybe i should say
some people say they have trouble
focusing when listening get content that
you're interested in initially
in the early stages you have to listen
through content that may not be that
interesting in order to get a toehold in
the language but eventually there's on
the internet there's an unlimited supply
of podcasts and interesting content
which i have used for all the various
languages i've learned over the last 10
years
there has never been a better
age in which to be learning languages
content abounds convenient tools
abound
so go to it and make sure you listen as
much as you can in order to improve in
your language so thank you for listening
bye for now